new movement tonight in the
ever-changing ever-increasing Democratic
presidential primary field a former
governor and a big-city mayor is in a
former Obama administration Attorney
General is not while the front-runner
among declared candidates is seeking to
solidify his socialist credentials
correspondent Peter Doocy shows us where
things stand tonight the first wave of
2020 candidates came from Congress the
next wave is coming from state houses
I'm John Hickenlooper I'm running for
president because we're facing a crisis
that threatens everything we stand for
the former Colorado governor joins a
field where many of the most excited
primary voters have made up their minds
because this weekend 12500 screaming
fans turned out in Chicago not to cheer
for the Bulls or the Bears or the
Blackhawks but for Bernie senator
Sanders took his Democratic Socialist
pitch to the radio this morning where he
pledged to legalize pot if you have
smoked a few times okay do a whole lot
for me my recollection is I nearly cost
my brain cells the 20/20 field won't
include former attorney General Eric
Holder who wants to focus on
redistricting and writes in The
Washington Post in evaluating potential
nominees we should remember that
creativity is not limited to the young
nor wisdom to those who are older we
must measure our candidates not by their
age but by the vitality of their ideas
some of those ideas were just on display
in Selma Alabama we are failing our
moral obligations when right here in
Selma too many of our children are dying
due to gun violence and how easy these
guns are getting in our streets in Selma
2020 candidate and New Jersey senator
Cory Booker was seen hugging the 2016
nominee Hillary Clinton whose family
brand is apparently fading the AP
reports her husband bill once a top
surrogate likely won't be next year
because quote so far none of the party's
early frontrunner has had a formal
meeting with Clinton nor have the women
who were running in the historically
diverse primary field Ohio senator
sherrod Brown says
he's two or three weeks away from a
decision on a campaign and had a chance
to check in with Hillary and Selma but
past Wall Street journal/nbc news poll
finds the president Trump begins his
reelection effort with four out of ten
voters saying they'll definitely or
probably vote for him and the president
has 16 months to try and improve that
number before Democrats even nominate a
challenger Brett Peter thank you